check out these two saudi princes
this one's the 57 year old crown prince
and this one the one doing all the hand
kissing is his younger cousin
listen to what the older cousin is
saying
he's being forced to give up his power
and to pass the crown prince title
to his younger cousin a guy who's almost
half his age
this is muhammad bin salman in the west
we just call him
mbs and since this moment in june he's
consolidated power so
swiftly and so thoroughly that in saudi
arabia they just know him as
mr everything
as crown prince mbs will become king and
with all of this new power mbs is
seeking to assert his dominance
throughout the middle east
one of his big policies has been a
vehement opposition
to saudi arabia's neighbor iran and on
that note he has found an
ally in the white house inside the
kingdom
mbs is also seeking to cement his
authority and dominance
over the royal family saudi arabia's
young crown prince arresting hundreds of
his own cousins
crackdown on corruption 11 princes and
nearly
40 current or former officials detained
reportedly being held at the lavish
ritz carlton yes if you're a saudi
prince
jail is the ritz carlton mbs called this
a corruption crackdown
and he branded himself as the
financially responsible
anti-corruption leader but we're talking
about a guy who recently purchased one
of the most expensive homes in the world
and who last year spent a half a billion
dollars on a painting
he clearly had other motives for this
crackdown beyond fiscal responsibility
one thing to realize is that the saudi
royal family is made up of thousands of
members who use public money
generated from oil revenues to fund
their unthinkably excessive lifestyles
so it wouldn't be hard for mbs
to crack down on anyone he wants to
coming into power mbs's second big move
was to loosen the strict
moral and social rules of the kingdom he
stripped the religious police of their
right to make arrests
he expanded women's rights in society
including giving them the right to drive
on the surface these are progressive
social reforms meant to modernize saudi
society but like the anti-corruption
crackdowns
the move is another effort to seize
power saudi society is built on a sort
of pact between the royal family
which is called the house of saud and
the vast religious establishment
run by conservative islamic clerics the
clerics give the saud family legitimacy
by giving them their blessing as rulers
of the kingdom in exchange the family
allows the clerics to strictly enforce
their uncompromising
puritanical version of islam within the
kingdom this faustian bargained means
that saudi princes like mbs and others
can live these indulgent lifestyles and
make deals with the west
but still retain religious legitimacy in
the eyes of the public
it's a balance that has kept the kingdom
stable in this very volatile region
but now mbs has violated his family's
part of the bargain
arresting hardline clerics who might
speak out against his progressive
reforms
this could shake one of the foundational
pillars of saudi society
the third way mbs is shaking up the
kingdom is his plans for the economy
the kingdom's revenue comes almost
entirely from oil
demand for oil has remained solid for
decades and saudi has reaped the rewards
of that
but in 2014 the price of oil started to
drop
and it became clear that betting the
entire kingdom's economy
on this one resource was a dangerous
strategy for the future
so mbs wants to end what he calls this
oil addiction
in order to prepare for a world after
oil he's laid out a vision for
privatizing a lot of the sectors within
the saudi economy
and breaking up this giant
government-owned oil business
but this reform could also create more
instability
thanks to the endless oil money saudi
citizens are entitled to a lifelong set
of benefits like free health care and
subsidized housing but as mbs
tries to privatize the economy and move
away from oil
this subsidized lifestyle that so many
saudis enjoy
could be threatened and the public
support that has kept this monarchy so
solid for so many years could begin to
dwindle
the kingdom of saudi arabia is on the
brink of one of the biggest
transformations in its history
as this young leader consolidates power
to upend the status quo
he may also upend the pillars that have
kept the kingdom one of the most stable
countries in the middle east
[Music]